[Music]  I just want her to be able to move on  and move forward in her life and not  feel judged or that what she was doing  was being ridiculed because I had  nothing to do with that and then I'm so  sorry  Danny Mathers tearfully speaks out on  Good Morning America  the Playboy model is dealing with the  fallout of body shaming a 70 year old  woman at an LA Fitness last July when  she posted a photo of a naked woman in  the locker room on snapchat with the  caption if I can't unsee this than you  can't either  I never meant to hurt her I never ever  intended on showing the world this photo  and that I hope that she could freeze me  last Wednesday Mathers pleaded no  contest to a misdemeanor count of  invasion of privacy she will have to  perform 30 days of trophy tea removal  served 36 months probation and will have  to pay $60 to the victim for restitution